this submarine is what experts are
calling the future of underwater defense
it's a nuclear-powered attack sub that
combines next-gen UK design with
classified us technology and it's being
built in Australia where it'll be
deployed in the 2040s the US doesn't
usually share this type of Technology
with its allies so the fact that
Australia is getting it is a massive
deal but the future Subs which are
estimated to cost up to 250 billion
dollars have been criticized by China
and Russia who say the vessels risk
sparking a nuclear arms race in the
indo-pacific so here's the secret U.S
technology that will enhance these subs
and how it might be used to counter
China's growing influence
the SSN orcus is being built with one
key feature in mind interoperability
that's the ability for all three nations
to integrate the same technology weapons
and nuclear reactors into their subs
to do this the US will share its highly
classified nuclear submarine technology
making the UK and Australia the only two
Nations to ever publicly receive these
systems Australia will also become the
seventh country in the world to own
these vessels which have greater
capabilities than their current diesel
electric submarines they can go farther
they can generally go faster and they're
they're quieter as well so there's a big
capability advantage in a maritime
environment Naval experts say the
submarine's design will likely feature a
larger Hull than Australia's current
submarines housing almost twice as many
crew members that crew will operate U.S
combat Control Systems which detect the
submarine's surroundings and direct its
weapons to their targets alongside U.S
Torpedoes those weapons will include
missiles fired from vertical launch
systems experts say these multi-purpose
silos will be similar to the modules
used in U.S virginia-class submarines
allowing all three nations to use the
same U.S tomahawk and Hypersonic
missiles a strapping a American missile
into an Australian submarine and having
it work absolutely seamlessly would be a
great advantage in any military conflict
all of these weapons will be
conventional as Australia doesn't have
nuclear weapons that means building the
nuclear reactors needed to power these
Subs on its own Shores could violate the
1968 nuclear non-proliferation treaty
the treaty limits the transfer and use
of Highly enriched uranium to
non-nuclear weapons States so Australia
will use what critics have called a
loophole for the first time in the
treaty's history the power units will
instead be built in the UK by
Rolls-Royce an enhanced for the US
technology to make them safer and
quieter they'll then be completely
sealed before being shipped to Australia
this Arrangement has sparked concerns
from campaigners who want to stop the
spread of nuclear weapons and drawn
criticism from China and Russia
is
China has said this could lead to an
arms race in the region obviously the US
and Australia deny those claims but
Russia and China do not like this deal
at all that's because of tensions in the
indo-pacific where the orcas Alliance
says these Subs will be deployed experts
say choke points including the Sunder
Strait and Taiwan Street as well as the
South China Sea are the primary zones of
interest for these Subs the way that the
US is seeking to counter China in the
region is that they're trying to build
up the capabilities of their allies and
this is one of the ways that the U.S is
doing that
but critics say that all this advanced
technology could be obsolete by the time
the SSN orcas is actually deployed
experts have pointed to the rapid
development of uuvs or unmanned
underwater Vehicles as both a challenge
to the importance of submarines and an
opportunity for their continued
relevance you might have one-man
submarine sort of controlling a fleet of
underwater drones but when you're
looking at such a big time frame 20
years in the future it's unclear how
much of a need there there will be
that uncertainty and the significant
price tag attached to these vessels has
raised the eyebrows of critics but
experts say the high cost shows how
important a stronger presence in the
indo-pacific is for the orcas Alliance
there is a growing recognition that the
U.S cannot do this alone China's been
pouring a lot of money and time into its
military buildup and to keep Pace with
China the U.S is going to have to seek
help from its allies in Australia really
is one of its biggest allies in the
region
[Music]